now the government's expected to publish
this long delayed
white paper on uh leveling up next week
um
do you expect it to deliver what you
have said that you wanted and
helped to bring an end to the
north-south divide
well thank you for having me on trevor
and certainly the government seemed to
have acknowledged the issue around
leveling up that we need to rebalance
the economy across the uk
and ensure that health and wealth and
opportunity is shared and new money is
always welcome but after decades of
underfunding the question will always be
is this going to be enough now of course
looking we don't have the detail but it
does seem to be a focus on affordable
housing which i'm really pleased to see
as someone who grew up in social housing
i know what a secure tenancy can do
to enable you to fulfill your potential
but it has to be about more than that it
has to be about skills when fifty
percent of the working population don't
have digital skills it has to be about
climate change when businesses are
washed away every two years by flooding
you can't level up that community and
culture you shouldn't have to leave your
community to go to london to fulfill
your dreams and finally it has to be
about transport and connectivity i've
been on your program before trevor
talking about our disappointment on the
integrated rail plan and now we have a
crisis in our boss network that lack of
clarity from governments about how much
money and if they're going to give any
money to the bus companies after march
has meant that bus companies are cutting
routes in exactly the places that need
leveling up like the five towns in
wakefield so it does feel like every
single department has to work together
it cannot just be about one person in
cabinet making these decisions we need
everybody to pull together and
unfortunately we haven't seen that from
the treasury as as yet yes let's i want
to come back to the issue of buses in a
second but just before we
uh go on to that indeed the last time we
spoke
um it was before the announcement on hs2
and you told me that what you really
wanted was a station in bradford a few
days later the government announced its
plans and there will be no new station
in bradford there is an issue
of trust here isn't there because at
that time i think
you had
a sort of um you thought that the
government might be on the same page as
you they clearly weren't um what makes
you think that you can trust them now
well you're absolutely right we were
poorly served with the integrated rail
plan the 96 billion that government
announced um it turns out that seven
billion is for west yorkshire six
billion goes for the trans-pennine
upgrade which is the electrification of
that line between manchester and leeds
which leaves us
the the grand sum of one billion pounds
which is for electrification between
leeds and bradford and sadly a survey on
how we can get faster trains from
sheffield to leeds so
disappointing and when i pressed
government to give us the detail of
where they were making these decisions
it seems that government and treasury
are just thinking about cost and this is
why i'm saying that people and
departments need to work together
because the idea of leveling up wasn't
factored in it wasn't factored in about
the opportunity for the people of
bradford to have a new station and what
that would impact and the money and
investment that would bring you see that
in the midlands that the just the pure
announcement of the new stations and the
new um the new rail network that brings
investment that wasn't uh in the
equation when government were looking at
what they would do with the integrated
rail plan so i will continue to press
the case but yes it was incredibly
disappointing
let's pick up a couple of the points
you've mentioned this morning first of
all on buses
how serious uh will it be do you think
if you don't get um
the services that uh so i understand
something uh that cut in half in some
parts of of your your area um
what impact is that going to have and
how serious how big a deal is it for you
it's a massive deal if you live in a
community that doesn't have a railway
station you absolutely need the boss
network and that's why when i stood to
be the mayor of west yorkshire i stood
on a manifesto of improving
our boss offer we've allocated a million
pounds to investigate uh public control
because we know that at the moment a
boss network that works for profit this
is where you end up when government and
the bottom line doesn't work and
government don't support you then sadly
you're starting to make cuts to that
service so we're getting um people
approaching us telling us that if that
bus network if that route ends they're
going to have to walk to work
we heard
a couple of months ago of a group of
workers who the only way they could get
to work economically to make it work
because there was no bus route was all
of them to go in one car and one of
their colleagues to travel in the boot
this is not good enough this is not the
west yorkshire i want to see we need a
proper bus network and if you're not
going to fund us on the trains please
when when we have our bus service
improvement plan i've been saying to
government we need the money we have a
transformational offer for government
you can't then ensure that the money
that we are
allocating for bus transformation is
actually about then managing decline of
the boss network
crikey that's that's a heck of a story
about you know boots somebody being in a
boot but um do you agree with uh your um
manchester mayoral uh colleague andy
burnham that key to this is not just the
number of services
but their cost and he's been pressing
the case that uh in london you can
essentially
have a single bus journey for one pound
55 whereas in your part of the country
it is far more expensive what would you
put that
subsidy for um
fares
as a priority for example over
uh fresh services
well i would suggest we shouldn't have
to choose obviously london doesn't have
to choose whether they get the service
or they get the fares it is part of a
complete package a fair tap in tap out
capped fair green buses
and routes where you you need to get to
that serve colleges workplaces and so on
but of course it's also about
affordability we have seen the cost of
living crisis the your other guests
spoke about that quite eloquently that
the the public are going to have less
money in their pockets and if you use
the buses on a number of trips you are
paying more because it's not capped than
those people who just use one bus to get
to work and back so my plan is to cap
the fare at five pound fifty and we're
working with bus companies already we're
not sat on our hands waiting for
government we're already working with
bus companies to try and make that
happen it's fair it's equitable and it
will mean that more people have access
to the boss